-And, finally, everyone,
it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go!
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets,
and we're all gonna vote
on whether or not
you like each one.
You all have voting clickers
at your -- at your seats there.
I can see the confusion.
This is fantastic.
[ Laughter ]
Now you can vote
for all of them,
you can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want.
And we're gonna see the results
live, right now, on the show.
Higgins, Roots,
you have the clickers?
-Absolutely.
-Got it. Clicking away.
-How was your average, Quest,
on this?
-I vote yes on everything.
[ Laughter ]
-All right,
so the average is pretty poor.
Higgins?
-I vote no on everything.
-Wow. So your average
is pretty poor.
-Well, yeah.
-Well, I usually vote
yes on most things.
But we're honest.
That's the whole thing, right?
We're being honest
with each other.
Yeah, now, here we go.
Yeah, someone just gave me
a thumbs up.
-Yeah.
-But, no, that's not the way
it's gonna work.
Green and red.
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
-Green means yes.
-Whatever tweet gets
the most likes,
we will tweet it out live.
And then, if you all like it
at home, you can WeTweet it.
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
-Oh.
-It's a shared experience.
All right, you guys ready?
Here, the first tweet is...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
"Who Let the Dogs Out"?
-Yeah.
-I like it.
-Yeah, I like it.
-I don't care for it.
-Yeah.
♪ Who let the dogs out? ♪
-♪ Who, who, who who ♪
-Yeah.
Who, who, yeah.
I don't know.
I think this one's like 50/50.
All right.
Votes are in.
Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Wow.
Almost exactly.
[ Sad tuba ]
-Wow.
-Almost exactly 50/50.
-Yeah.
-But it is non --
it is a non-WeTweet.
-No, non --
-No, that's it. No.
-Who let the dogs out?
Ha, ha ha ha.
-Yeah, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
This next one here is...
♪♪
All right.
Yeah.
-You call them dumb.
-Yeah, yeah, exactly, yeah.
Let's see the results
on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
Yeah, no, same thing.
-Wow.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Sad tuba ]
The audience is very honest
tonight, yeah.
They don't love it,
they don't hate it.
They go, "I'm fine with it."
-It's like, "Yeah, whatever."
-Indifferent.
Yeah, here we go.
-This is a winner.
-This next one, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-This one's gonna win.
This one's gonna win.
-I think this one
might be the one.
-Yeah.
-This one might be the one.
Yeah.
-All that technology.
-It was the biggest deal ever,
and now -- yeah.
All right, let's --
-Like a Segway.
-Let's see the results.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love that you're honest!
I love this!
-191!
-I love my audience!
You guys are the greatest.
Thank you.
You know when to give it up, and
you know when to not give it up.
They're like,
"Yeah, I'm saving it."
I agree with you so far.
Next up, how about this one?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Ooh.
Oh, wait, the music's slow?
I mean, what is that?
-It's thinking.
It's a thinker.
-Yeah, I know, it's a thinker.
Yeah.
No, this is gonna flop.
-Yeah, this is gonna be
a big flop.
-No, this is gonna be disa--
this might be 100% no.
-Yeah, this might
be exact opposite -- 191 no.
-You think yes?
-I have faith.
-I know, but you said
you say yes to all of them.
-Yeah, I do.
-All right, well, let's see
the results on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
Yeah, yeah, no.
[ Sad tuba ]
I already know.
The iPad's gonna be the winner.
-Yeah.
-All right. But let's see.
We have one more.
Here we go.
-Is this the last one?
-It's the last one.
Here, how about this?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-I like that one.
-Yeah, people are
nodding their heads
like the old "Muppet Show."
-Preach!
-Yeah, it's like --
People are doing a lot of this.
I think --
-"Where am I?"
All right, we gotta beat 191?
-I don't thi--
It's gonna be close,
but I don't think
it's gonna beat it.
-It's like 172.
-Yeah, 172.
-I think this is 195.
-Ha!
-Let's see the results.
-Oh!
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Sax solo ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Sax solo ]
[ Exuberant sax solo ]
♪♪
[ Song ends ]
[ Feedback, off-key notes play ]
-Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]